how often am I actually doing these
things that I love and if it's not very
much then maybe we need to rethink our
priorities about why is it that we don't
have the time to do the things that we
love and so much of that has to do with
because we have to pay for the expensive
car and the trip that we just took that
we didn't use points for you know like
all these things that add up to where
we're like stressed out about having to
pay off this this and that and this is
an interesting thing so every hundred
dollars of recurring expenses that you
can cut out of your life per month is
actually thirty thousand dollars less
that you need to reach Financial
Independence thirty thousand most people
spend 500 to a thousand dollars a month
on their car so we're talking about a
thousand dollar car payment right that
fancy car you're leasing it forever 1000
bucks a month that's three hundred
thousand dollars more you need to reach
Financial independence with that
thousand bucks a month I have my prior
car for 15 years it gets me from point A
to point B and when you compound all the
money that I've saved have done that it
literally has hundreds of thousands of
dollars like I kid you not that's what
it comes out to so it can be a massive
difference I think a lot of people would
like yeah I'd like a new car like that
sounds nice but how much is that worth
it to you compared to the results and
the reward of what you're saying that
hey if you saved it is that worth more
than the nice car and that's the
inspiring part because I think a lot of
people are like yeah I would love a nice
car but do you love that more than the
ability to retire this many years
earlier and having that x amount of
money double quadruple if you just
invest it and buy the cheaper car like
that's the thing that I have to do in my
brain yeah I love that thought process
that was Brad Barrett a certified public
accountant personal finance expert and
host of the top 50 business podcast
choose fi it is a passion for financial
Independence and helping people take
action to make their lives richer in
every way with Focus points on money
saving hacks having a positive mindset
and living a happier healthier more
intentional life Brad achieved Financial
Independence at 35 and lives in Virginia
with his wife and two daughters he was
featured in the playing with fire
documentary one that I recommend to
people all the time definitely go watch
it you do not want to miss out on this
episode though because I found a big
boost of inspiration in my own personal
goals and financial Independence you
might find yourself reevaluating your
life or some big financial decisions by
the end of this so let's get into it and
enjoy the episode
foreign
I'd rather buy a couple quality pieces
of clothing and wear them over and over
again for ages knowing that the product
was made sustainably then buy cheap new
clothing every season with the
ever-changing fashion trends
contributing to more and more waste
enter Indigo Luna I am so amazed you
guys by how beautifully made and how
high quality their clothing is and how
soft it is they're an ethically made
small business of yoga wear swim
Intimates and more their material is
sustainably sourced everything is cut
sewn and dyed by a loving human hand and
they ensure that every person involved
in production Works in comfortable safe
conditions I'm amazed at how flattering
and comfortable their clothing is every
time I go into the closet I want to
reach for my Indigo clothing pieces
because they hug my curves just right
and just make me feel so good throughout
the day and I feel comfortable yet
beautiful everything is made in these
beautiful simple shapes with earthy
colors and plant dyes from recycled or
organic materials this is the type of
thing that is totally worth spending my
money on I love being intentional in the
way that I spend my money on my clothing
by buying less but high quality pieces
that last in my closet for years I feel
so good about my purchases and I love
what I'm wearing so I got you guys a
discount code enter the code Ellen 10
for 10 off your order or click the link
in the show notes by using my link
you're supporting the podcast to stay up
and running so thank you for being here
thank you so much Brad for being here
um I'm really excited for this
conversation for anybody who doesn't
know a while ago I made a YouTube video
called how to become financially free
this was about three years ago and I was
talking to my friend uh Quinn and
telling you about how I'm creating this
video and he's like oh you know what
there's this guy Brad who is in Maui
right now on a vacation or something
like that and he's like he has this
awesome Financial Independence podcast
you should see if you could chat with
him for the video so I emailed you or I
forget maybe Quinn connected us and it
was so awesome to be able to just hop
over to the place you're staying at for
your vacation and I just asked you a few
questions for the YouTube video I love
how that video turned out and thanks for
coming on that before yeah well hey it's
great I that did work out incredibly
incredibly well with the timing for two
at his timing yeah we were actually my
family was visiting Maui essentially for
a month which is kind of part of
financial Independence and the beauty of
of having options which I think to me is
how I look at Phi anyway and one of
those options was hey let's go to Maui
for for three or four weeks and and hang
out so yeah it was neat uh that Quinn
connected us and that we got to meet
yeah totally so we've met before we're
doing this one virtually but we have met
before which was really cool so for
anyone listening who doesn't know what
does Financial independence mean exactly
yeah so okay so there's the the
technical definition let's say which we
can go into but but I think what I what
I just talked about is is really the
more important aspect of it it's instead
of instead of living
and working for material things and just
kind of really wasting your life energy
on on things that don't matter
necessarily to you and might just be
like oh the person next door bought a
fancy whatever car or whatever it may be
fill in the blank so of course I'm gonna
do that it's it's just kind of it's
waking up from from just sleepwalking
and I think I think it's implied
applying some intentionality to life
with the umbrella of getting your
finances straight because when you're
stressed financially
Nothing Else Matters right if you are
living paycheck to paycheck you're in
the red every month you have to take out
loans or you know payday loans or credit
cards
that's the stress that is pervasive in
your entire life and I think once you
start on a path towards being
financially free
everything in your life gets better
because and it's not about you have to
reach the technical definition of
financially independent and never work
again like to me that's that's
irrelevant it's that very first time
again if you were living paycheck to
paycheck and you have a thousand dollars
saved up five thousand ten thousand
imagine how many more options you have
in your life imagine how much less
stressful your life is because what used
to be an emergency right like a flat
tire or my washer and dryer whatever
something broke that's not an emergency
that's just life because you have you
have the savings you have some net worth
you have some space where you're not
stressed about this all the time so I
think that's kind of the the overarching
theme of okay let's get some space let's
give ourselves some options some
flexibility some freedom and then it's
like this Cascade Ellen it's this
wonderful Cascade of everything in your
life gets better because you can focus
on the things that actually actually
matter you can focus on your health and
your relationships and your community
and hey what do I want my finite time on
this planet to look like right like we
get 80 90 years if we're lucky and so
many of us spend it working in jobs that
we don't really love and if there's a
way to kind of step off that hamster
wheel by being intentional and saving
and reframing saving money from oh this
is horrible this is deprivation I'm on a
financial diet to oh wow you mean I get
to buy back the only resource that
matters which is my time and I think
that changes everything
yeah so you were in featured in a
documentary which I recommend to people
all the time playing with fire anybody
listening or watching this that hasn't
seen that documentary definitely go
check that one out it's very inspiring
by the end of the documentary you're
going to be just rethinking your whole
life
for sure so how does this differ from
maybe like the Dave Ramsey financial
piece uh way because I did interview
Rachel Cruz on the podcast a while ago
about you know getting out of debt and
starting to save and that aspect so
what's different about what like you
advocate for just like the financial
Independence Community advocates for our
company yeah it's a great question and I
think Dave Ramsey and his entire
organization obviously you spoke with
Rachel his daughter I think they have
done marvelous things for tens of
millions of people and the impact that
they've had on this world is remarkable
and you will never hear me say a bad
word about Dave Ramsey or anyone yeah in
his fear in that regard I think what
they do is they get people
from a position where they're most
likely in debt things that the the house
is on fire in essence their hair is on
fire financially and and they have to
take drastic steps and I think the cut
and dried nature of his seven baby steps
are there's no equivocating with it
right it's just this is clear you need
you know what you need to do and then
you're at a point where okay I forget
what his seventh is but it's like uh you
know donate and live whatever like live
in abundance right it was something it's
the live live like no one else so that
later you can live and give like no one
else which I love that which is
wonderful and giving I mean that's
that's a beautiful part of living a a
wealthy life we're living a
well-balanced life so I I really
genuinely love everything that he does
but but I think he's very doctrinaire
about hey credit cards are evil you can
never never never open a credit card
you should not I guess put in I think
one of his was uh don't get your 401k
match and I don't want to get into the
weeds of the of the little minutia of
personal finance but for me your 401k
match or anybody listening who has a
retirement account that is free money so
that is like wow I can get essentially a
hundred percent return on my money
by getting the match at my company
that's part of my salary in essence but
Dave says don't focus on that Focus
first on getting out of debt and and
again I get it because that's part of
that's part of the steps so I think how
I choose to look at Financial
Independence versus Dave Ramsey's
message is
Phi is really for people who who are
looking for that next step
and you know once you get Beyond sixth
or seventh yeah yeah all right once you
get there and maybe you're looking and
and I don't want to say that we have
like Advanced strategies because I
actually don't think about there are
Advanced strategies certainly but that's
not like a prerequisite for being a part
of the financial Independence Community
it's uh those things are available but
if you're looking for a little a little
bit more you're looking maybe like I do
I use credit card rewards points to
travel the world and I use credit cards
to me a credit card is my most valuable
Financial tool when used properly but
again Dave has it right in the sense
that tens of millions of people get in
credit card debt so of course you want
to steer clear of it if that if you're
worried about that but for me I have a
decent net worth I have a significant
net worth and and I'm not worried about
having an issue paying off my credit
card so I a credit card is a bonanza for
me it's free it's free money right so
well because for you you have the habit
of paying it off down to zero every
single month paying it all the way off
and so I love Dave Ramsey's message and
Rachel kurz's message of like look a lot
of people spend more than they would if
they weren't using a credit card I mean
like they spend more using a credit card
than they would if they were paying cash
or whatever so that message is so
helpful for so many people who need to
like get into the habit of what you're
doing of paying only for what you can
afford what you can actually absolutely
and that's almost like a beat and what I
say is like don't use a credit card
unless you can pay on time and in full
every single month if you're not doing
that don't just cut up the card forget
we even had this talk you know like
don't even think about it but so yeah so
I think we apply apply a similar level
of intentionality but it's more it's
more it's broader I guess is is how I
look at it is okay there are lots of
different things you can do again when
you're finding it it's that little bit
of financial Savvy of hey it's not my
the house is on fire once I've got some
stability I now am focusing on a savings
rate right so I'm focusing on how can I
cut things out of my life not for like a
diet sake not for this is short-termism
we think long term right that's what the
fight Community I think what typifies
the fight community so much is we think
long term and I focus on things I value
so I don't think anybody would look at
my life and say I'm cheap or miserly at
all like I I'm rolling in abundance but
I'm doing it very intentionally based on
what I value right so I value my health
and fitness I spend a boatload of money
every month on my health and fitness I
value automobiles
essentially zero so I'm driving a 2013
Honda Civic and before that I had a 2003
Honda Civic until about two years ago I
don't care at all I'm not trying to look
rich I don't care about that I want to
spend where I want to spend money where
I get the most value from it so I I
think though that that's a very long
answer to your short question Ellen but
but I think it's really important and
then you know obviously we we get into
crazy strategies and there's all sorts
of there's so many smart people in the
financial Independence community and
that's what's really great about it is
it is this worldwide community of people
who are living more intentionally and
you get people from all different
backgrounds and knowledge bases and it
it's really cool when you can kind of
come together and we call it like
crowdsourcing the best information and
it just cuts through the learning curve
right like you don't have to learn it
all on your own you don't have to be the
smartest person in the world because you
have this community at your back and I
think that's really powerful
yeah and essentially like the the
message that Dave Ramsey and Rachel Cruz
are sharing is is a lot of the same
things like it's all within the same
community of like Financial Independence
um I feel like but is is I feel like the
playing with fire might have a little
bit more emphasis on the retiring early
aspect
yeah do you think yeah and to me that
you know I think the biggest and why you
you keep hearing me say Financial
Independence or the five movement it's
not in my mind it's not the fire
movement even though that it's it's so
catchy right like I mean that that's
really why it has caught on and has
continued to catch on even though we
have done our damnedest to uh to get rid
of that the re because I think honestly
it's a distraction it's the financial
Independence retire early for anybody
who's who's not intimately familiar with
it but the retire early it carries so
much baggage
and and I think people like to get
caught up in that and then throw out all
the beautiful message of financial
Independence and just focus on that
ridiculous retire early of oh is this
people who are just looking to opt out
of life who don't want to be productive
members of society or whatever other
nonsense thing they come up with that's
you know just straw man argument right
and and I think to me like I don't know
one person who has retired early and sat
around on a beach and sipped umbrella
drinks all day yeah right like yeah yeah
absolutely it's such a distraction but
but yeah I mean I think retiring early
in the sense that you don't want to go
to a soul-sucking job that you're just
doing to earn money and in return you're
giving up the only resource that
actually matters and that's your time
right and and like I'm not anti-job
obviously we have to work we have have
to earn income it's even if even if you
look at it as just a means to an end
it's still valuable so like I'm not
anti-job at all but do I think working
in a job after you've reached Financial
Independence a job that you maybe don't
like do I think that makes sense I I
really don't uh I think you should
probably you know depending on your
situation think about finding something
else to do valuable with your time and
so I think that's kind of the subtle
distinction that I I like to make with
the the retire early aspect of it yeah
when I think of retire early I just
think that I have the freedom to do what
I love doing not to just sit on the
couch and veg out all day it's that
that's not even something I would want
to do it's just that I would have the
freedom to do exactly what drives me and
inspires me and that involves work like
work is something very like natural I
feel like but it's work that you love
like that's just at least that's my
motivating thought no I love it I love
my job I love my job I love that like
this is my job that I have like my
podcast and my channel and everything
but but getting to a point where Andrew
and I have our goals to be like okay now
I can just do it based on based on what
I love not based on oh I need to make
sure that I take this and get this
amount does that make sense or I could
focus more on homeschooling with the
kids and do less or whatever it makes
perfect sense and I think that is that
is exactly what fire is all about and I
love that that's what you've gleaned
from and it's so cool that again you did
that video a couple years ago and and
watched playing with fire and I I'm
curious like how did it how did it
impact you
oh that's such a good question I think
it just is very motivating to keep
um to keep on this like path that we're
inspired by to be careful with our money
be intentional with the way that we're
spending our money and
um the way that we're bringing it in and
then knowing what to do with it my
husband is very good at um he's just
always been very good at being not
spending very much he's a quite Frugal
person he also doesn't have a very
materialistic at all mindset like he
cares zilch about looking rich or
whatever right
um and for me I enjoy spending money on
nicer things cert like certain things
items like Quality Furniture whereas my
husband would be more likely to be like
oh let's get the cheaper thing and so
that aspect after watching the
documentary is just helpful to keep okay
there's certain things where we can
spend less on and we don't need this
particular thing and our long-term goals
it's just inspiring to continue on that
path yeah that's great and I think one
of the things that jumped out to me from
that movie in particular was how how the
filmmaker Scott rickens and his wife
Taylor how they how it brought them
closer together right and it sounds like
you and Andrew that that that's been the
case as well in the sense that like
people are coming from different
different backgrounds and different
standpoints and like if this can help
Foster conversations over things that
really money is one of the last great
taboos and it doesn't have to be and
that to me is one of the most beautiful
aspects of this is that wow we can talk
about this we can be on the same team
because we actually have a goal now
right like we have something like a
North star to shoot for and that looks
different for every family or every
person every situation because I can't
tell you what your life should look like
or want so and that's nobody's place but
but once you start talking about this
then you can dream big and you can
figure out how do we how do we get there
what does there even look like or what
are the things that I like doing I think
that was one of the most poignant
aspects of the movie was was uh Scott
asks his wife Taylor to write down I
think this would be a good exercise for
everybody listening is write down the
five or ten things that you really most
love doing on a a day-to-day or week to
week basis and I think they were both
very surprised on both of their lists at
how few of those things actually cost
money cost any dollars I think the the
most expensive was like have a glass of
wine together and that could cause as
little as or little or as much as you
want right and like it's it once you see
it on paper
it's it's an incredible thing because
then okay there's no there's no lying
here we we have it on paper what what
this means and how does this impact our
plan going forward and and what do we
want that plan to look like so anyway
it's uh it's all part and parcel but I
think that's a pretty good exercise for
everybody
I think that's such a good idea too
because people might write down what
they love doing and see how often am I
actually doing these things that I love
and if it's not very much then maybe we
need to rethink our priorities about why
is it that we don't have the time to do
the things that we love and so much of
that has to do with because we have to
pay for the expensive car and the
mortgage and the trip that we just took
that we didn't use points for you know
like all all these things that add up to
where we're like stressed out about
having to pay off this this and that but
if we're mindful with our money then we
can work less do do less of what we have
to do to make our income right and then
more of what we actually really love
which tends to be free yeah it's so
fascinating right and and yeah to your
point which is brilliant of hey you're
you're paying you're working to pay for
all of these things that you can't use
because you're working all the time it's
like this horrible recursive Loop of
like yes oh my God I bought an expensive
car and a fancy house that I'm not using
because I'm working all the time to pay
for the things and I bought them maybe
just to make myself feel better then you
know I need some luxury or something
it's so silly
I know it's so interesting and going
back to like how my husband and I our
mindsets like over time I become so much
better I mean I've always been good
about saving like even when I was in
college I would work to save but then I
would save that money to spend it on
like a frivolous thing that I definitely
don't have in my life anymore you know
some kind of material thing and so over
time that material drive has become has
gotten less and less but Andrew has just
always been at that where he just
doesn't need nice things for the most
part of his life and so when we're
together I'll be like oh we should we
should get this thing and he's like yeah
but if we spend that amount of money on
that then we're gonna have to you know
work this much longer and all that I'm
like ah you're right maybe we don't need
that so it's good it's good to have two
different I feel like about a balance in
a couple like is your is your partner
the same on the same path as you are one
of you more of a spender than the other
yeah it's a good question so
uh yeah my wife Laura is is also fairly
she's naturally Frugal she's actually
probably more naturally Frugal than I am
so you know we're we were pretty lucky
from the beginning like I wish I had I
almost wish frankly that I had some like
cool story of like overcoming but but we
were both we were both natural Savers uh
but you know it's interesting because I
think there are people of all types I'm
thinking about my own podcast right so
like my uh my uh long time co-host he
actually just stopped a couple months
ago but uh his name is Jonathan and and
him and I are the exact opposites he he
calls himself The Reluctant frugalist
and I'm like the natural saver which is
so I like that word reluctant frugalist
I like that right I think that's and I
think a lot of people really relate to
relate to that because I think he looked
at it as oh this is this is serving a
larger purpose you know in his case it's
uh it's buying Electric trying to
gadgets and if okay if I don't buy all
these electronic gadgets you mean I can
now maybe reach a point of financial
Independence where I can spend time with
my kids or do do these other things that
actually matter to me like I think most
of us
I know it sounds crazy but like we don't
connect our spending with our time and I
think that was what was so beautiful
about the book your money or your life
that came out decades ago with Vicki
Robin and Joe Dominguez and it's it's
talking about literally Your Life Energy
goes into every purchase you make and
it's just that that thought and and you
know it's not to say don't make
purchases that that clearly I I want to
make entirely clear to everybody
listening like I am not miserly I'm not
cheap I'm not nothing of the sort it's
just
think it's important to be intentional
and I think like once you break that
that habit Loop of just hey I have money
I'm gonna go buy something because it
feels good in the moment like and you
just you just create that little bit of
space right between the stimulus and the
response and it may it does make a huge
difference and especially then further
still when you have this this goal this
Guiding Light of
okay this is what I this is what I
actually want out of my life because you
know Ellen to me it like one of I'm not
one of these like anti-media people but
but I think I think what the media often
gets wrong with personal finances is
they make it seem so difficult they make
it seem impossible you hear all the time
like 98 yeah I'm making this up
obviously 98 of Americans will never be
able to retire or they're you know you
hear like they're gonna live off cat
food and it's like is social security
gonna be there and like when people hear
those kind of things
they essentially just throw their hands
up right like or the Susie ormans of the
world telling you you need 10 million
dollars to retire right like if you need
10 million dollars to retire then why
even bother who's going to get to 10
million like what percent of people are
going to have 10 million dollars one out
of 10 000 I mean what are we talking
here so the other
9999 people they throw their hands up
and they say this is stupid why do I
even bother as opposed to what we do in
the financial Independence Community
which I think is really one of the
biggest positive aspects is is we we
create like a very simple equation and
this is not for anybody who's not a math
lover this is uh it should not turn you
off because what this actually does is
hey I control what my number is I
control what my life costs okay and then
therefore I know how much income I need
every year to cover my life so for
instance religion is very simply let's
say your life costs it doesn't matter
that's the beautiful thing also it
doesn't matter if your life costs forty
thousand dollars a year a hundred
thousand or five hundred thousand
dollars a year it's it's just an
equation but there's some certainty and
there's some control to it of saying
okay Susie Orman says I need 10 million
but what the heck why 10 million that
that doesn't make any sense I mean like
my life costs fifty thousand dollars a
year that's what I actually need to
cover
okay so you can do that with some kind
of side hustles some you know passive
income if that exists or just living off
of some of your Investments so I think
that's why we say okay you need to have
a net worth you need to save during your
working years and then you get to a
point where you have some assets and
because those assets grow every year you
can pull some of that money out and in
theory it won't exhaust itself so you
can pull some of that money out now
again I don't want to get bogged down in
the math but just very simply hey if
your life costs let's just say eighty
thousand dollars a year I think that's
probably a number that people could
could relate to you just multiply that
amount by 25 okay so in that case it is
two million dollars so that would be
your Phi number your financial
independent you're financially
independent when you have a two million
dollar net worth now again that's a big
number I'm not not saying anything
otherwise but you control it right so
what if you paid off your mortgage what
if you paid off your cars and your life
only cost forty thousand dollars
well now you just cut that fly number in
half right so you only need a million
dollars because you can pretty reliably
pull about four percent out of that that
pot which is why a million dollars four
percent of a million dollars is forty
thousand dollars so that's that's kind
of how this number works and again let's
not get back down in the math but just
knowing that it's not some elusive day
it's not the media it's not Susie it's
not even Dave Ramsey or me or anybody
telling you you have to have X number of
dollars it's just hey I control what my
life costs and then therefore I know
roughly what my fine number is going to
be and that's there's Great Value
psychologically especially in in having
some sense of what that is
yeah and someone might even hear you and
be like even a million dollars how am I
gonna that's gonna take me forever to
save that amount of money but this
doesn't mean that you're like oh I'm
gonna retire the next three years five
or even five or ten years but what you
can see is like the long-term goal of
look being intentional with the way I
spend my money now is gonna potentially
affect how early I'm gonna be able to
retire even maybe 10 years earlier than
I thought I was actually gonna have to
retire and that 10 years makes a
difference even 15 years like it just
depends on how how um far you're willing
to go how much like how hard you're
willing to work for one in the beginning
right and how much how Frugal you're
willing to be which could equal buying a
five thousand dollar car cash instead of
getting a forty thousand dollar car you
know that that those types of things
make big differences in the long run and
I love what you said about the
um how few people are being intentional
with the way that they spend because you
think you're like in the in the now and
you're like oh this just feels good and
I want to to give an example of a friend
of mine who she loves to spend she'll
totally admit that and that's part of
her love language even is spending money
on people that she loves and her
children and stuff like that so came
over for a play date once and she's like
I'm gonna bring some snacks I'm like
great that sounds great come over for a
play date we'll all play outside the
kids will play football and she came
over with like 10 of these like amazing
mangoes they're these like incredible
cute mangoes that cost like seven
dollars a pound here on the on the
island and she brought like 10 of them
and like five or six different like
craft kombuchas and the kids were all so
excited for it I'm like dang you just
spent a hundred dollars on snacks and
I'm like that's so nice of you and so so
nice and then later as we got in the
conversation about finances because
she's like super interested in it I'm
like well as an example like you could
have just bought like two of those
mangoes and that still would have been a
really special treat and we didn't
really need like seven or eight and you
would have saved a lot of money just
there so like little things like that
like add up over time and that's just
like a little example I thought of no
it's a great example and I mean I think
maybe even to like add on to that is
sometimes then like to me the spice of
life is getting together with friends or
like that's what I want to get out of it
and sometimes if people feel oh this is
like a heavy lit I know your friend
isn't in this situation but like oh it's
gonna cost us forty dollars for a
potluck when like I just want my friends
to come over like I you know it like
sometimes the money gets in the way and
I I know it's kind of a like a random
tangent but you you wonder sometimes
like what is the essence I think this is
ultimately what I what I'm getting at is
like what is the essence of of what
you're doing and and I think like like
for me the example that I always use is
my wife and I would always love to uh to
go out to like uh craft breweries right
so uh I'm not a beer a big Beer Drinker
anymore I'm kind of uh I'm gluten-free
now but but it back in the day we we
used to and and I think we looked at
each other and we're like you know every
time we go out it's costing us Thirty
forty fifty dollars even just like you
know for three beers something crazy
we actually just want to spend time
together
so what we did was we wound up going to
our local grocery store where they have
an amazing beer selection and we got
just a bunch of fun six packs and they
cost a dollar a dollar fifty a beer
right and and again it's not necessarily
the money it's not like just being cheap
for the sake of being cheap it's it's
trying to find the essence of what are
you trying to get out of a situation we
were just looking to spend time together
so every day at five o'clock for years
we would have a happy hour and would
cost us three dollars and we'd have a
little time away from the kids and we'd
go out on our back porch and that was
what we were looking for not oh let's
get a babysitter oh let's go to the
brewery and spend all this money like
this and we actually wound up doing it
more often because it was so easy and it
was so cheap and it was right there and
we knew we were actually looking to get
out of it so uh so yeah like those
little things are are really important
but you don't you don't get that with an
unexamined life right like that's again
is part of the beauty of this is like
you can take a step back and say oh what
am I looking for from my life and I
think uh you know I hate to sound like a
broken record but like it's just it's so
important it really is
yeah totally and in the example that I
just gave about my friend too if she had
come over with a couple of them and
maybe one of the kombuchas we still
could have shared all of that together
and had that experience
um and had a little bit of it together
and if that was something that she was
looking for to save money so that was
just like a funny yeah no it's a great
example and just going back to something
you said a minute ago I'll say where
you're like you know the the person out
there who might be hearing about science
like you don't have to get there in
three years or five years it's it's
nothing like that I think I think how I
kind of conceptualize it is
most of us who are just kind of
sleepwalking through life and and living
that kind of YOLO existence of I'm gonna
just spend everything because it feels
good
you're gonna wake up 30 or 40 years from
now and you're probably gonna have no
money
you know so if you apply just a little
bit of intentional and it's you don't
have to overhaul your life but just a
little bit
like you said I mean you said 10 years
15 years I mean Ellen that is you think
about a normal 80 year old life that's
that's 20 of your life that you just
reclaimed by a little bit of
intentionality that's that's a mammoth
difference Mammoth so yeah yeah because
the difference of of living
intentionally with your money versus not
is you're good if you don't live
intentionally you're gonna get to 70 and
you might find yourself having no money
and still having to work and still
paying off a house and still you know
all all that aspect so does that mean
that you don't spend your money on
anything you can still pick and choose
what's important to me and that can even
go for material things like I said for
me I really value buying Quality
Furniture if I'm willing to spend money
on in that area and where am I willing
to cut where am I willing to save in
other areas like having a cheap car
exactly and for those people you know
both you and I are we're not evidently
car people but there were people who
greatly value their cars so like I don't
want to make that like the the boogeyman
here of like oh you can't buy a nice car
like that's the be-all end-all if you if
you want to spend money on a car go for
it if you truly value it if you're doing
it because your neighbor got a BMW and
you want to keep up that's kind of
stupid if you're doing it in my in my
estimation if you're doing it because
you truly value it go for it that's the
beautiful thing like you can make
decisions but but but but there's a
finite amount of money right so let's be
clear you need to make decisions again
it's not deprivation you're not living a
terrible life but you need to make
decisions because you cannot afford
everything unless you just make an
inordinate amount of money and then
you're probably not listening to this
podcast or mine right like about about
saving money and getting financially
independent so uh yeah I mean to me it's
just about choice and it's about
intentionality
so you're a CPA an accountant and you
said that you're always been Frugal
right so what what point in your life
did you realize was it something like
numbers and numbers come across and
you're like wait a second if I did this
I could retire like what was your story
that made you realize and why are you
passionate about it
yeah that is a great question so yeah I
mean I guess I have always just been
like there were all these like family
stories of me like going back to like
when I was 13 and I like worked in a
comic book store and I saved every
dollar you know it's just all these
silly little stories but uh so I think I
did naturally have it but for me so I
had a couple of inflection points in
terms of like the numbers and then kind
of like the value of Phi so the numbers
when I was like 19 years old I wound up
getting an internship which sounds super
fancy and it was not at all but like at
this local this investment firm and it
was it was terrible honestly it was just
like cold calling client it was you know
I I didn't learn all that much but what
I did learn which changed my life which
was just like a lightning bolt was one
of the Brokers sat me down in front of a
compound interest calculator of okay if
you put at that time I think like the
Roth IRA contribution limits were like
two thousand dollars a year or something
and like it was okay if you put put in I
was 19 years old so if you put in two
thousand dollars a year for the next 20
years and then it it grows at whatever I
think I put in 10 a year which is not
outlandish I was like I gained it out
until I was 99 I was you know
essentially like a billionaire or worth
like 500 million dollars or something
crazy like that and and you know the
example again I'm doing this for memory
the example is silly but I think the
lightning bolt moment was oh wow
compound interest and compounding your
money matters so very much and the
number of years that you can be invested
also matters significantly and now
that's not to say somebody who's getting
a late start is screwed and they should
not start not saying that at all but
clearly the sooner you can start
investing the better and it was just
like it was just so eye-opening to see
that small amounts can turn into massive
amounts when you think long term so that
was that was the big aha moment and for
me so can we explain then and can you
break down the stock market and just how
to how to save your like what you do
with the money when you get it because I
think a lot of people listening might
have okay I'm on the track of the Rachel
Cruz Dave Ramsey I listened to that
episode I'm getting out of debt and
maybe I'm starting to save even like 500
a month like what do you do with that
money where like can you just I think a
lot of people are intimidated by the
stock market like they're like I'm
afraid to put my hard-earned money
somewhere that I just don't know where
it's gonna go I could lose it I don't
know what to do with it I don't know
which account to go in so can you just
give everybody some baby steps and
simple things that just help them feel
confident moving forward on how to
invest their money so that they can have
that reward of what you're talking about
yep no I absolutely can and I think one
of the nice things is that there's never
been a better time to be an investor a
personal investor small scale investor
and not have to rely on some expert to
do it that you can actually do it
yourself off and I think you know it's
funny because I know you said sure I'm a
CPA and I I should have some Financial
knowledge but but investing was always
really scary to me because it it always
seemed like something so you're actually
talking to the me of 10 or 15 years ago
so I can very very much relate because
this truly was me
and it seemed scary it seemed like
something that you needed an expert that
there was some Insider knowledge that
you were you know all these other
buzzword the playing the market and
you're gambling and and I think the the
thing that changed my life was a book
called The Simple path to wealth by J.L
Collins who's actually become a friend
of mine he's a a the Elder Statesman in
the Phi community and he's uh he he
applied some certainty to and I think
investing is actually one of the the
only areas of life that I've ever seen
where the less you know
the better results you're going to have
I kid you not I know that sounds insane
but truly the less you know the less you
fiddle
especially the try to outsmart the
market try to time the market by selling
and buying or getting a hot tip on Tesla
or whatever whatever the stock du jour
is
that's that is like a loser's game
and the all the studies bear that out
like I look at life almost in terms of
like the poker table like what is what's
what are the decisions I can make that
give me the highest likelihood of
success in the long term
and what actually has been proven over
and over again is that uh Index Fund
investing so in essence buying a little
piece of hundreds of companies all at
once because Ellen I think the the
biggest kind of step back here before I
even get into that is when you're buying
a stock when you're when you're
investing in the stock market or truly
investing in a company you're actually
buying a little ownership piece of that
company we don't think about it like
that because we think about it like I
said of playing the market or gambling
or whatever or I'm looking to make a
quick buck and is this going to go up or
down in the next couple days
no I I think that's the wrong way of
looking at I think you should look at it
as hey when I buy a share of stock of
let's say Amazon
for instance
I'm buying a little ownership piece of
Amazon and all of their worldwide
operations
that's a fundamentally different thing
than I'm buying a little piece of paper
or digit on the computer that I hope
goes up and down and you look at wow
what is what is this business going to
do what are the two million people who
work for Amazon those are now people who
are working to do their job to do all
these good things you know bring these
essential items to people and now I'm an
owner of that business so in essence I'm
reaping the war the rewards of a
well-run business and a profitable
business and you know again I'm using
Amazon as an example but when you invest
in let's say an S P 500 Index Fund
you're getting a little piece of 500 of
the biggest companies in America
so you're you're getting a little
ownership piece of that and you don't
have to be smarter than the market you
don't have to be some Titan of of Wall
Street or someone of these ridiculous
hedge fund people which you know you can
hear the sarcasm dripping from my voice
like I don't think those people know
anything frankly like after all is said
and done like after all the fees they
charge you I don't think there's any way
that over a 40 or 50 year period which I
think is the only way to look at this is
long term that they're gonna outperform
just the market
it's never been proven that they can
which again then gives certainty to
people like me from 10 years ago and you
know the the people that you just wanted
me to talk to is
you don't have to be smarter than the
market you can just buy the market and
there's never been an easier and cheaper
way to do it than going to a very
reputable company like like a Vanguard
or a Fidelity or Charles Schwab and
opening up an account
and just you said five hundred dollars
put that 500 in there every month or
every X number of weeks that you can and
just buy an S P 500 Index Fund or a
total stock market index fund and
you know again I I'm not supposed to
give Financial advice I'm giving
Financial advice to myself from 10 years
ago like this is what I I would have
done what I do today Ellen so like
obviously everybody's situation is
different but like that to me is the
highest likelihood of success because
you're not getting crushed with those
fees you're not getting crushed with
timing and letting your your little
human brain get in the way of oh I'm
scared or oh the Market's going up and
now I want to put all my money in and
like we we get it wrong we just get it
wrong and we need to take our brains out
of it which is why if you just do this
week after week month after month year
after year decade after decade you're
gonna wake up with more money than you
could possibly imagine and again like I
said the less you know is actually the
better in this sense because it it helps
you sleep at night you're not trying to
beat the market you're just trying to
match the market and it's super easy I
mean I think most people listening to
this could open up an account add a
Vanguard I'll use Vanguard for instance
because because I think their their
customer service is great and if you
have a problem you call them up and they
they walk you right through it because
they've helped millions of people like
you do this and they understand that
it's daunting and it's scary but it
really doesn't have to be and that's the
cool thing you just you link up your
bank account you send the money over you
know just Google Vanguard Total stock
market index fund you'll get like a
little uh it's called vtsax and again
I'm not giving Financial advice of this
but like that's what I invest in and you
just buy as many you buy 500 worth and
then a month later you buy another 500
worth and uh I think it's actually
pretty pretty easy which is super cool
yeah I think there's there's gonna be
people listening who are in the position
that I have people in my life like this
who are like okay I'm I'm out of debt I
just paid off you know car payment or
loan or college loan or something like
that but now maybe they just have the
mortgage right and then they're wanting
to save some extra every month but they
just have it in like a regular bank
account like a regular savings bank
account they just don't know what to do
so I think this information that you're
giving is really helpful and then
there's other people listening who are
going okay I definitely don't have 500 a
month but the message that you have of
finding little ways to cut just start
somewhere start somewhere where you can
what way can I save five ten dollars a
week the 10 to 30 a week that I can cut
out by not spending on this or what
subscription doesn't make sense for me
in my life anymore that type of stuff
adds up and then before you know at the
end of the month you're like wow I
actually have fifty dollars a hundred
dollars to save and that's where it goes
to what you're talking about yeah that
is exactly right and and yeah the 500
was just you know we we just made that
just a random number yeah since you said
like the person who might be just
leaving it in there in their savings
account and I think I think again there
there is there's psychological certainty
to that because it feels safe of I'm not
gonna lose money right but but I think I
think the best way to show what you're
actually losing by not investing in the
market is it's the concept of
opportunity costs it's what am I giving
up so sure let's just say I'm gonna make
up a crazy number because it it'll just
be easy for illustrative purposes of a
hundred thousand dollars let's say you
you have a hundred thousand dollars
sitting in your bank account okay you've
saved up for years and years and years
and which is a remarkable thing or you
know fill in the blank you gotta it's in
somebody's will you got a hundred
thousand dollars right so you don't want
to lose it you don't want to you you
want to hold on to that as tightly as
you can but in like a regular bank
account you're essentially going to get
no interest right it's just going to sit
there so 30 years from now or let's say
40 years from now it's still going to be
essentially a hundred thousand dollars
because it will have not it will not
have grown you wouldn't have lost
anything right so you succeeded wildly
and you're hey I don't want to lose I
want this to be safe
but but what did you give up and I think
that's where when I was talking about
when I was 19 years old and I saw this
compound interest thing I realized that
oh the money grows and it doesn't sound
like a lot at first but that's the
beautiful thing of compounding and I
have kind of a back uh just like an easy
math way to do it is
in rough terms and of course we can
never know the future right but like in
general terms the stock market goes up
on average about eight percent per year
okay now again who knows what's gonna
happen in the future but let's just
we'll just use that for instance that
means your money will double
basically every nine years
okay so uh every nine years which is
amazing so now like I said 40 years
we're talking there's four and a half
doubles in there right because 9 18 27
36 and then essentially another half a
double so what that means is a hundred
thousand goes to two hundred thousand
then four hundred thousand eight hundred
thousand one point six million and then
we still have half of a double so we're
going to get over two million dollars
okay so just by having invested that
hundred thousand and then basically
going to sleep because like I said the
people who perform worst in the market
are those who are watching CNBC every
day or listening to Jim Cramer or Susie
Orman and and oh is is now a time to
sell no just go to sleep don't worry
about it and sure there are going to be
times where that that balance goes down
30 in a year but then it comes rip
roaring back and if you sold at the
wrong time
you would stop all that compounding so
again let's say two million dollars
right so that is the concept of
opportunity cost is what was I giving up
so in that first instance yeah you've
got that hundred grand it's sitting
there safe as can be it's in Fort Knox
basically right FDIC insured you're good
to go but you would have had over two
million dollars through the beauty of
compounding so you and not to mention
not to mention that what that hundred
thousand dollars worth is worth 30 years
from now is less so you actually are
losing money because it's not worth a
hundred thousand dollars in 30 years
anymore yeah that's a brilliant point so
yeah inflation certainly by as we
certainly as we know from the last year
or two uh yeah that's a that is a great
great point to add on thank you so much
for doing that Ellen and yeah it's what
it is it's both of us it's both of them
it's wild so you know that like that's
just that compounding I think for people
conceptually to understand like oh in on
average my money's gonna double every
nine years and that's it it's wild when
you look at potentially like what your
net worth is today and you're still
saving like so I mean it's gonna for
people who are still saving their money
is going to double well quicker than
every nine years which is another kind
of cool wrinkle to this you know just as
you're conceptualizing like a net worth
or like we talked about earlier of oh
it's about my fine number is about 25
times my current spending right and it's
all kind of Pardon parcel I know I said
I didn't want to get bogged down in the
math but like I think I think we've done
this where the numbers are they make
enough sense that I think people
understand that the conceptual framework
you don't have to get back then because
plenty of people get bogged down is it
is it 25 times my annual expenses is it
30 is it like you can quibble at at the
margins and and I understand that it's
important at some point but
realistically like I look at it as like
like North Star as opposed to you know
the Susie's of the world saying I need
10 million or 15 million or whatever
ever it is
I don't care about that I care about my
North Star my North Star is my life
caused this I multiply that by 25 that's
the number I need to hit and then when I
have the the power of compounding on my
side it makes it a whole heck of a lot
easier
yeah and I think your illustration is
really important because a lot of people
are going through life thinking oh I
just can't save and you know it's not
worth it even that what's what's the 20
extra dollars gonna do this week or the
30 extra dollars because I'll save later
or like I'll I'll get there eventually
but the importance of what you're saying
that if you start now it's that I say
this over and over in the podcast not
just related to finances but in anything
in life of like the short-term hard work
for long-term gains if you're always
procrastinating and putting it off for
later like you're gonna get to the end
and be like dang it I should have done
that I shouldn't have bought this this
or that that I didn't really need and
didn't actually bring joy in my life I
could have saved it and quadrupled my
money yeah you're right and made life a
lot easier to to have more freedom of
time like you said yeah everything good
comes from that long-term thinking in
every aspect of life it really is yeah
so I have a question though about right
now like I know what you're saying that
you just don't worry about when the
market dips and like you know it'll
eventually go up and just don't look at
it and don't fiddle with it but is it
different right now like there is such
an ins like insane amount of inflation
people are worried about how much money
they've already lost in the stock market
if they already do have money like what
are your thoughts right now about people
who are maybe on that trajectory but
they're seeing they're seeing some
really insane things happening yeah no I
mean listen I I totally get it and I'm
clearly a human being with uh with
feelings and emotions and and and I get
the the fear I think we all a lot of us
live through that
multiple times in our adult lives
especially not not least of which was
was March of 2020 right when it looked
like who knew what was going to happen
with the stock market it was plummeting
and what is the future going to look
like so
believe me I know how important the
psychology is and I think
it can never be overstated like you need
to like I I know I'm a CPA and I know
I've been talking a lot about math but
I'm not actually like a math guy when it
comes to it because I think the like the
sleep well at night test is something
you need to pass with with a lot of this
which is even and I will get to your
actual pertinent question but like even
like with uh like paying off your
mortgage right I think for a lot of us
not for people who are getting mortgages
now but people who have gotten mortgages
in the last handful years you've got an
all-time low rates they're like two
three three in the threes uh percent I
mean that is historically low you almost
certainly could if you were talking
about hey do I pay off the mortgage
quickly or do I invest the difference
like the investing because right like
you grapple with this I grapple with it
we all do and it's like
mathematically it almost certainly
almost certainly makes sense to invest
it
at that low interest rate but the sleep
well at night test is man wouldn't it
feel amazing to have no mortgage right
like how wonderful would it feel so I
get that I'm I so get it and I'm so
sympathetic to it that I think I
probably am even more on the side of the
emotion
but I think you need to understand what
is like useful in that sense of like
that is truly psychological well-being
as opposed to fear-based
reaction right and fear-based reaction
is hey the stock market just went down
10 I'm gonna sell everything and go back
in that bank account and that money is
just going to sit there forever because
man once you sell it's really hard to
get back in it's really really hard and
you know you
you're thinking long term and I think of
course and it's going to depend on who
the person is right like if you're
looking to buy a house in a couple years
or that money is sitting there to pay
for your kids college and that's
happening next year that's a totally
different scenario than someone we're
talking about like you're investing for
retirement 20 30 40 years from now right
I think for people who have that
long-term mindset and the long-term
timeline
think you really need to try to avoid
the noise
and I know it's hard I really I truly
know but for people who are investing
now who are just getting started maybe
they're listening to this podcast and
they're like oh wow maybe I should go
open that that you know and invest in a
low cost account right like open the
account today
there's probably no better time to
invest than when everything
is on sale right if you think about it
like we talked about when you're buying
shares of stock or you're buying mutual
funds
you're buying an ownership piece of a
company
so if you don't think obviously for
something that you think the company has
changed dramatically or there's
something terrible well that's that's a
different story but if we're talking
about just like Amazon.com or I keep
using that's a bad example like Warren
Buffett's Berkshire Hathaway or apple
right like companies that people love
if it's 30 off now from where it was
last year and you don't think anything
fundamentally has changed but just that
that people are scared right now
well in every other aspect of life when
things are on sale people flock to it
right like we want to buy on sale but we
don't want to buy stocks on scale we're
scared to death to buy stocks on sale
interesting
when you think about that and it's like
oh I'm still getting that same ownership
piece of this company
but I'm getting it for 30 less or 50
less so if you're in that stage of Life
which most of us are where we're saving
money and we're still in that
accumulation stage
seeing all this all this happen all this
turmoil is actually not a terrible thing
at all because you're able to just keep
on accumulating shares of that same
company for a fraction of what you would
have spent in the high-flying years of
of a year or two ago
yeah that's interesting and this is like
a tangent question but since you've
brought up like specific businesses it
makes me think of
um like conscious investing because I
have a lot of um like a lot of my
audience a good chunk of them I think
are really careful and conscious with
the way that they spend their money
ethically and might not agree with
certain businesses that are really big
top businesses like a lot of people have
a problem with Amazon which is why I
actually stopped it yeah I realized
but a lot of people love it a lot of
people don't there's there's pros and
cons
um things that people love about it
things that people don't love about it
like it's chain it's made life a lot
easier in so many ways but then it's
also people have trouble with the
Monopoly aspect so I just think of
multiple businesses that like maybe an
ethical vegan like myself where you're
investing money and you don't know if
you're investing in McDonald's or
different animal food type of product so
what is that something that ever comes
into your conversation and to me that
sounds like it would be a little bit
more detailed where you have to like
pick certain things which makes it
something that's more Savvy not as the
whole just put it in there you don't
have to think about it but I'm just
curious if that's something that's on
people's minds as they're listening yeah
yeah what a brilliant question it is
unquestionably on people's minds and you
know I I I struggle with this honestly
and I think it's because like I'm I'm so
sympathetic to that to the Viewpoint and
like you don't want to invest in
companies that you find abhorrent or you
think are doing terrible things right
like
yeah I mean there there certainly are
mutual funds that I think the ESG they
call them and uh yeah sustainability I
forgot I I unfortunately don't know the
exact acronym but uh ESG and
yeah I mean I think the tough part is
like you said you in essence are picking
companies and I think that
just from like a long-term math
standpoint like I think that is where
it's just so hard and I I don't you can
tell I'm conflicted you can hear it in
my voice because I don't have the answer
to it it's like what what I what my my
thought for my own life is
I'm using this as as my my wealth
building strategy and then I can spend
that wealth in the ways that I see fit
and adding value to the world giving to
the organizations that I want to give
that that's that's how I sleep well and
I I don't think that's a satisfactory
answer for most for everybody no it is
about
but interesting nuanced conversation
like I see both sides to it because what
you're saying is like look the way that
I'm actually going to spend money in my
life is going to be like towards the
companies that I find ethically sound
that you really like but when it comes
to investing your money it's just it's
like a whole different ball game to just
be like I'm gonna pick and choose like
it's just very different yeah it is and
it's just oh man it's to me it's just
such it lowers the likelihood of you of
you reaching your financial goals which
are really your life goals then and it's
so that's why I'm so conflicted it's
like I know I know there are so many
people and I said I'm sure there are
companies that I'm invested in that I
that I find abhorrent and
but it's helping me reach my financial
goals which I think helped me make the
world a better place so yeah it's it's
hard it's so hard you could go in
circles you know yeah yeah I'd be
curious anyone listening or watching if
they could share in the comments their
thoughts on it because I I find it very
very confusing to know like what what
you're supposed to do because it's kind
of just infiltrated everywhere unless
you're like super Finance like
financially Savvy with that I don't know
if that is something that you can just
pick and choose yeah yeah it's hard but
but there are many of those options for
those ESG funds so uh I have never
really dove into the exact Holdings of
each and uh but it certainly is better
than picking in just one individual
stock I think that that's a very tough
game so you know it's probably kind of
almost meeting in the middle in terms of
like a total stock market index fund
versus a single stock
okay so to switch gears you mentioned uh
this book you love called the simple
path to wealth and I wanted to ask you
like what what exactly is wealth is it
just money or is it also wealth and
happiness and lifestyle because it
sounds like to you like it's all
intertwined
um in regards to the financial
Independence aspect you know because a
lot of people might be thinking you know
money doesn't bring you happiness it's
these other things but that's kind of
your point is that you don't need to be
making all this money to spend it on
things it's that you want to make money
to be able to and be careful and
intention with your money so that you
can live a life that is about like your
your wealth of happiness and lifestyle
can you elaborate on that a little more
yeah so for me certainly wealth is not
just a number I think uh you know that
that would just be I know there are
people who keep scorecards of like how
much they're worth and that's like you
know determines their their value in
life I just think that's just a pretty
sad existence and like to me
if you but but
saying that money is not important
I think it's also equally silly
because
whether we like it or not the world runs
on money it just does and you need to
have you work for money you give up that
again the only thing that matters which
is your time you give it up in order to
earn money mo the vast majority of us do
right and
if you can get to a point where just
being intentional and living below your
means and saving money
can get you to a point of not having to
trade that time for for money for in a
job that that doesn't light you up
well I mean if of course I'm gonna do
that right like of course I'm going to
live that intentionality and of course
I'm going to save and then to your point
about you know the word wealth I think
then it affords you the ability
going back to what I said before like
the biggest stressor in most people's
lives it's money
and when you don't have that stress then
you can have a wealth of X fill in the
blank right you can have a wealth of
connections you can have a wealth of of
health and fitness that maybe you can't
devote the time and energy to when you
have to drive to your job and spend nine
or ten hours there and drive home and
you're exhausted right like you can
cultivate relationships you can give
back to the community you can do all of
these things that I think make a truly
wealthy life
and not just numbers on on a computer
screen like if if it stopped and started
with numbers on our computer screen
I think you've lost at The Game of Life
already and and I think it's just it is
so much more but but to me that is the
lead Domino that's that having some
space financially and it doesn't mean
having millions of dollars it doesn't
mean even being at Phi right like you
have when you have like I said before
five thousand dollars saved up or you
have a six-month emergency fund well you
have power that you never had before in
your life you're not beholden to a job
that tells you to do the wrong thing or
something you don't agree and you talked
about about ethical investing well what
about unethical things that go on every
day or just things that are against your
value system that you don't have to do
anymore because most of us are worried
about our lives falling apart
in 30 60 90 days right like if you got
fired because you stood up for yourself
or you left and you had no income for 60
days
most people are gonna have a tough time
paying the mortgage they're potentially
going to lose the house like they can't
stand up for themselves
well when you have money saved up you
sure as hell can stand up for yourself
right Everything Changes
and I think that to me is just it's like
such another crucial aspect of what
we're doing here
yeah I love what you said and on top of
it when we talk about money going the
making the World Go Round it just
reminds me of how money is like an
energy exchange so if you're being
intentional with how you're spending
your money or not spending your money in
in certain ways then in other ways you
can be intentional in ethically
um made companies and sustainably stores
like for instance the shirt I'm wearing
like it's I know that the shirt I'm
wearing was created by uh women who were
ethically treated ethically and that it
was the material is ethically sourced
like things like that that I'm willing
to spend more money on that I'm being
careful to spend less in other ways and
then I'm willing to spend more money in
in these certain ways like the example I
just I just explained so I think I think
everything you said is so so fascinating
and important so for people listening
then can you explain some tips for
reducing their spending where are they
overspending how can we maximize our
income
um and savings to not be a slave to our
job let's just break down some of your
favorite tips
yeah I think uh you know for most of us
it starts with
just being honest with yourself
financially maybe for the first time so
again
super stressful finances let's let's
just be honest here right like most of
us don't want to talk about it most of
us don't want to think about it right so
we have no idea what we're spending we
have no idea what our finances look like
because we're scared because we're
nervous because we know it doesn't look
good right so what do you do when that
happens you stick your head in the sand
you procrastinate
that's easy you know my life hasn't
blown up yet so I'm gonna just keep on
keep on rocking and rolling right so I
think
really the the thing is you got to be
honest you have to sit down and just get
it all on paper okay so like my very
first thing just to get started with is
just write it all down so go
hey what what am I bringing home look at
your paycheck right what am I bringing
home and then just go to your bank
account go to your credit card and you
don't have to tick and tie every dollar
because again when you get bogged down
in detail you stop because it it's
uncomfortable and it doesn't feel good
you know but just get close hey what
does my life even cost some of us don't
have any clue like how much are we
spending on cable every month or or our
cell phones or whatever or all these
recurring things there might be
recurring subscriptions in there that
you don't even know you're paying
anymore right like you might have signed
up for whatever Apple TV to watch Ted
lasso and now and now you haven't
watched in a year and you're still
paying every month because you just
forgot and again because you had your
head in the sand which again is
perfectly normal
you didn't look at your your bill so you
didn't see that it was there so that
that clearly is the first step but then
also as clearly is you need to take
action right like you need to make some
change if you're living paycheck to
paycheck or you're in the red every
month you're you're in a negative you
have to you have to do something and I
think
as much as again this is not about
depriving yourself the easiest way the
first steps are to cut things because a
lot of us a lot of us have those
subscriptions that just keep on rolling
and we don't know about or we're
spending in ways that are Mindless and I
think a lot of people like low hanging
fruit is I've seen is food food budget
like a lot of us and it's it doesn't
mean don't buy high quality products
that clearly is not the case but I think
a lot of people because they're so
stressed all the time because they
haven't planned they haven't done any
type of meal planning they're very
reactive and I think anytime you're
reactive you're you're just kind of
beholden to the moment and you have to
you have to eat right theoretically so
you have to you pay what you pay so uh
whereas if you sat down on a Sunday and
meal planned for the coming week and you
bought ingredients and you bought
compliment entry ingredients that could
potentially get you two different types
of meals right and you make you double
up the quantity so then okay I just have
to cook two meals and maybe that's four
dinners for for our family and maybe
there's some leftovers maybe if we're
Super Lucky we're we've got five meals
out of this
okay well then you're not scrambling so
you're not stressed you don't have to
waste that time it's almost invariably
going to be cheaper
I mean in 99 of cases to cook at home
than it is to go out last minute hey
I've got to run to the grocery store and
grab something from the hot buffet for
thirteen dollars a pound right like
that's what a lot of people do
but so it's planning ahead I think for
most families for most people there are
hundreds of dollars a month in in food
savings not by eating a lesser quality
but just by being intentional I think
you know just a simple example that I
use which is is my kind of value my
valueist is is the phrase we use uh okay
I'm not depriving myself but but I want
to be intentional so like my cell phone
for instance
most people spend whatever it is a
hundred dollars a month even today's day
and age 100 a month plus on a cell phone
for unlimited data and and this and that
well I looked at it and said Oh you mean
there are there are a lot of these
companies like mint mobile or Republic
Wireless that when you're on Wi-Fi you
have unlimited data and talk and text
and it costs like 10 or 15 dollars a
month and you get maybe one or two
gigabytes of data which is not that
great but it's not terrible and
that's Gonna Save Me 85 dollars
per line basically or thereabouts right
so for my wife and I it's like we're
talking like 160 bucks a month that we
saved by going to Mint mobile or
Republic Wireless and because we're on
Wi-Fi 99 of Our Lives the only thing we
had to give up was when we're not on
Wi-Fi we basically don't go on YouTube
or download podcasts that literally
that's the only decision I made and
that's 160 a month that's almost two
thousand dollars a year oh yeah that's a
that's a big one I feel like that's
that's something that a lot up do I mean
one of the things that we do is we have
we have Horizon but we don't have
unlimited because that was like an extra
thirty dollars a month so we're saving
thirty dollars there but we have to be
intentional that when we're out and not
on Wi-Fi to not really like use it very
often or else we're gonna get like an
overcharge but like my husband had
calculated even if we got an overage
charge like two times a year that still
would be less than if we had the
unlimited and paid the extra thirty
dollars a month so things like that but
what you mentioned is is really uh I
think even better it's saving a lot more
money but you know in to your credit you
you two applied a lot of intentionality
to that which is awesome like you
thought that through and okay maybe it
doesn't make sense to just YOLO and like
of course we want the unlimited because
we can afford it right like it's the
thought process right like even for
anybody listening to this it's not even
the little the little details you can
save on on your phone you can save a ton
of places but it's the thought process
of oh maybe there's a different way
maybe there's some little change that I
can make like going back to the happy
hour that I talked about before like
maybe there's some little change that I
could make and in this case like you
said it's not so little I mean that's
that's a massive savings but is it is it
saving and giving up nothing in return
no of course not you always have to make
a little adjustment but like I said in
my case I just don't download podcasts
when I'm not at my house I download them
before I'm you know while I'm at my
house and I listen to them in the car or
whatever so I'm not really giving
anything up but I just have to be a
little bit intentional so I think like
that that's really the the thought
process behind but yeah for most people
it's get this down on paper look for
those recurring subscriptions that are
just eating you up that you didn't even
realize were there and then you know
maybe look the low hanging fruit of you
could probably save a couple hundred
bucks a month in food maybe a cell phone
and then you get into like bigger things
obviously of if you're
cars you mentioned before like we were
talking about cars and I I mean most
people spend
five to five hundred to a thousand
dollars a month on their car
well I mean is that probably the best
way to spend your money if you don't
value it like no you could probably buy
a car and hold it for instead of leasing
a car or whatever like I've had my car
for 10 years or I had my prior car for
15 years and it gets me from point A to
point B and I mean when you compound all
the money that I've saved on that it
literally is hundreds of thousands of
dollars like I kid you not that that's
what it comes out to so it can be a
massive difference
yeah the car is a really important one
because a lot of people listening to
this might be living in a in a place
where status is just all around you like
I know I grew up in Orange County where
everybody almost everybody had really
nice cars doesn't mean that they could
afford it just because they looked like
they had the money doesn't mean they
actually have the money and the amount
of people that are hey are buying new
cars when they really don't can't afford
it like I think what is the Dave Ramsey
thing that you shouldn't buy a new car
until your net worth is like a million
dollars something really out something
really provocative like that's a really
provocative statement because so many
people just buy new cars and that
doesn't mean that they don't value
because you're saying oh maybe you just
don't value having a nice car I think a
lot of people would like yeah I'd like a
night a new car like that sounds nice
but how much does that is that worth it
to you compared to the the results and
the reward of what you're saying that
hey if you saved it is that worth more
than the nice car and that's the
inspiring part because I think a lot of
people are like yeah I would love a nice
car but do you love that more than the
ability to retire this many years
earlier and having that x amount of
money double quadruple if you just
invest it and buy the cheaper cart like
that's the thing that is that I have to
do in my brain yeah I love that thought
process and just to kind of even bring
it back to numbers right is uh and this
is an interesting thing so every hundred
dollars of recurring expenses that you
can cut out of your life per month right
hundred dollars is actually thirty
thousand dollars less that you need to
reach Financial Independence thirty
thousand so we're talking about a
thousand dollar a thousand dollar car
payment right that fancy car you're
leasing it forever a thousand bucks a
month
that's three hundred thousand dollars
more you need to reach Financial
independence with that thousand bucks a
month three hundred thousand wow so
that's real now and you can apply that
then right like the 160 bucks that I
saved on my cell phone that's like 50
grand less that we need fifty thousand
dollars just for making for not
downloading podcasts when I'm out of my
house yeah yeah that like that's the
this is the ticket to the stuff that is
inspiring because I just picture myself
even listening to this conversation
while I'm doing dishes where the kids
are in the background and I'm like wait
a second I need to reevaluate like where
can I cut my spending because that that
reward is is something so few people are
talking about yeah yeah it's it really
it's important and and I think it's it's
providing that that impetus you know for
people that to feel that they can really
do this they can affect change on their
life right like that's why we we talk
about this stuff that's why we talk
about like making better changes and
making decisions in your life it's you
actually can affect change on your life
it's not some like elusive they that's
impacting you it's you you can make
positive changes and like I just find
that so compelling and rewarding and
it's just like you can tell it lights me
up it's just it's amazing
yeah it does so you talked about the car
which is bigger is a bigger ticket item
what about like the other bigger factors
that are in like the playing with fire
documentary of people who literally
moved their entire life to a place that
was much cheaper to live in like I'm
living in one of the most expensive
states in America like for us that's
something that is the value of being
able to grow tropical fruit fruit food
in our garden was like something that
was worth it to us and we figured out
all the other ways that we could
sacrifice like my husband worked 50 to
60 hours a week for the first like
couple years when we moved here and that
was like a sacrifice that we made
because of our long-term goals but some
people have the obstacle opposite goal
where they're like okay where can I work
less
um and have a cheaper everything yeah so
what are your thoughts on that yeah it
this is hard this is real hard because
uh I mean where you live is is the most
personal of things and and I I don't
want anybody to walk away from hearing
this conversation and think like oh I
have to do something like on the playing
with fire documentary they moved from
from San Diego and and they were trying
to find somewhere cheap to live like
that there's no one path to financial
Independence and that's the picture that
I've been trying to paint this whole
this whole hour so far is is
any positive change you make is going to
help you right now let's not I mean we
you know what's what's the saying the
call speed of spade like clearly
your path defies just all things equal
is going to be longer living in Hawaii
than if you lived in Alabama or
Mississippi or in Richmond Virginia
where I lived right like there's no
question about that but but you've made
a very intentional decision that this is
this is the life we want to build and I
think that's the most important aspect
of any of this conversation so you know
myself personally and I can give you
like really the most personal example is
I grew up in the suburbs of New York
City so I grew up on Long Island my wife
and I grew up eight minutes apart and
you know we're both CPAs we could have
made a life there unquestionably like we
had we had upside potential we weren't
making a ton of money when we when we
moved away but you know we were 25 26
years old and we had we could have both
been Partners at a big accounting firm
or so whatever it was
but we knew that we would always have to
give something up that we didn't want to
give up
and that was not worth it to us so
living
in the only place we'd ever lived right
with all of our family and friends that
was obviously a big draw and it was not
easy to move away but it was in service
of a future that we wanted to live into
right and for us that superseded that
future goal of one of us staying home
with our future kids they didn't exist
at that point and they were fictional
future kids as they call it like and
that was more important
so that was a decision that we made that
was I mean that's not an easy thing to
move away from your family and friends
but it was in service of a life that we
wanted so I think if you if that matters
to you
you know this is a very personal
calculus and and it's not my place to
say what everybody should do or what
anybody should do but but I think if
you're asking me like you know
will it help you to move to a lower cost
of living area where for me at least
like everything was cheaper I mean Ellen
it's crazy like my car insurance was
half the price our utilities were half
the price the groceries were a fraction
like the house was a third of what like
of course it's easier obviously that
that it's almost like self-evident but
that doesn't mean it's the right
decision for everybody
so I I think you know that's the best
way I can answer is with my own personal
anecdote
no I think that's good I think
I almost don't even consider though that
they
they look you don't have to be stuck
into the situation that you're in right
now but that kind of leads me to my one
of my last questions that I also asked
Rachel Cruz when I had her on the
podcast that
um is it a privilege to even have this
ability to like for instance some people
are so so strapped for
um in the situation they're in maybe
they're a single a single parent or they
have a super super low income job and
just don't know how they could possibly
cut cut in any way in their life like is
it a privilege to even be
having this conversation like what what
are your thoughts and takeaways on that
yeah I mean I think there's there's no
question it's a privilege I think
anybody who thinks otherwise is is kind
of foolish or deluding themselves
obviously
without question this this message of
financial Independence reaching
Financial Independence
this is not going to be applicable
tomorrow
to everybody it just isn't and you know
why why I said at the very beginning is
this
that you know that said
the benefits of Phi I think are broadly
applicable to everybody
in the sense that
we know how stressful finances are it's
the only like when your finances are in
bad shape it's the only thing that
matters it's all pervasive it's there at
every moment and if you can get to a
point and I don't begin
to say that I can I can put myself in
the shoes of someone working three jobs
and that oh just save extra money like
there are people who do that cavalierly
like like they could just make changes
and that's ridiculous but
but I think for nearly everybody
we can make some small changes that that
will put us in a better position
tomorrow a month from now a year from
now like I said back at the beginning
that first time you have a thousand
dollars saved or maybe not even a
thousand maybe 200 or 500
things that used to be an emergency
aren't anymore
and that is a vastly better place than
if you were you had a payday loan for
500 so it might take you that might take
you a long time to get to that point
but I think having the agency that that
know how that like I'm making positive
changes for myself and that saving this
money it actually matters
I feel like that will make it that makes
a difference to people that that having
that that bit of agency really does help
so so yeah I mean the short answer your
question is like yes obviously there's
privilege and it you'd be a fool to say
somebody making a hundred thousand
dollars doesn't have it easier than
somebody making 50 and somebody making
50 doesn't have it easier than somebody
making 20. right and but I I truly
believe with every fiber of my being
that this is a message that can help
everybody I really do yeah I agree yeah
I love the way that you put all that and
then on top of it for people who are
listening because if you are listening
to this on a computer or a smartphone
likely you have the means and the
ability to at least make some changes in
some ways like if you have that if
you're at that level right where you're
even listening to this on a podcast
um or on YouTube or whatever but it is
inspiring to note that like the more
that you are intentional with the with
the way that you save your money and the
way you utilize your money then as you
get to a place of a little bit more
freedom then you also have that freedom
to help others who are not in that
situation and that that's part of the
the beauty of them that message I think
yeah yeah I totally agree totally agree
okay so final like encouragement
takeaways for anyone listening like what
how should we end this is there
something that you'd like to share for
people listening as a final take way
yeah I think uh well thank you for
listening I think I think this is really
important and I think
like I said that that agency the the
being able to take action I think that
is like the thing that has emboldened
people most that is that listened to
choosify All These Years or or even for
a short time is
that we constantly say you can take in
all the information you want right but
if you don't get up off the couch and
take action your life isn't going to get
better and there are people out there
that want to support you
in just in our own Community we actually
have choose fi local groups when I was
in when I was in Maui we have a chuse of
high Maui group we have Facebook groups
and and 300 cities all across the world
25 plus countries of people who are
looking to support other people who are
trying to make their life better and but
it starts with you it starts with you
getting up off that couch and taking
action and and wanting to make your life
better and I think I think all the info
is out there and I think you can do it
and we've we've had so many people who
have changed their life dramatically in
a short period of time and I think you
can do it and I think I think it can
start today
love it cool thank you so much for this
conversation I think that I think I'm
just like listening to it and being I
could go re-listen to this and just be
inspired and pumped by it so I
appreciate everything you're sharing the
numbers I know you're saying you're
trying to stay away from the numbers but
I think the numbers are inspiring nice
well I appreciate it and thank you so
much for having me on this is a blast
love all the questions and and yeah it's
uh this this is important stuff and I
think uh it's just cool that we can we
can all just make our lives better so uh
again thanks for thanks for letting
letting me share the message
of course and guys please go check out
his podcast choose fi and just continue
listening and being inspired all right
we'll end it here thanks for being here
thanks again
[Music]